alors pourquoi vous l'arrivée comme ça
c'est comme ça c'est pas surtout nous
dit qu'il veut appeler bon et à la
rentrée regardez en soirée lors et les
canadiennes pourquoi gelés pourquoi vous
êtes assis la semaine
pourquoi un ca de chiens gonzesses pour
mon passage pierre kalfon tient jusque
est ce que tu peux baisser un peu la
lumière voilà
linehan 86 moi je t'ai vu pour la
première fois aussi au tintamarre donc
c'est dans le star is born président
beurre ensuite bon il ya eu un triomphe
c'était le café de la gare en 90
l'olympia en 89 il dix ans après qu'en
99 djamel connaît un succès comparable
parce que j'ai retrouvé des des articles
de l'époque avec des phrases qui
derrière ils pourraient dire aujourd'hui
c'est une phrase de vous y avez un
numéro deux actuel qui vous avez été
consacrée pratiquement c'était au début
je me serrait la ceinture marie penser
la ceinture qui me sert est-ce que c'est
dur de voir arriver la relève comme ça
absolument pas non d'abord djamel je
venais depuis très très longtemps on se
connaît depuis huit ans il a tourné dans
les deux papas les mamans et j'ai senti
tout de suite dans le regard de ne
jamais une envie et puis il est tout à
fait normal de faire place aussi aux
jeunes comme aussi d'autres maintenant
je fais place à d'autres
et c'est bien cette cette espèce de
passation de pouvoir non j'ai aucun
souci et puis il est tellement efficace
et puis je crois que à partir du moment
où le public le soutient
c'est qu'il ne s'est pas trompé ouais
donc maintenant pour chacun de nous je
crois que c'est le plus dur c'est pas de
réussir en plus dur est de durer mais là
aujourd'hui
à 23 ans même mois à 23 ans je n'ai pas
eu l'occasion d'avoir le succès qui la
banlieue vous quand même
jamel debbouze et y est j'ai fais pas de
banlieue en fait nous et non moi j'ai
toujours voulu ajustements être très
très large public depuis toujours je me
pète le dirt et les beurs j'ai toujours
refusé
je fais toujours refusé d'être à lettres
un porte drapeau
mais je pense que lui aussi il est
fédérateur je dire elie talent alors
vous êtes capricorne non capricorne
ascendant vierge
vous êtes né le 3 janvier 58 étaient en
fait j'ai compris beaucoup de choses
vous concernant que je plaisante pas dix
ans et il est déjà très américain en
fait vous êtes très capricorne parce que
par exemple vous avez du mal à profiter
de ce que vous avez acquis oui parce que
je suis sans cesse à me remettre en
question voilà et vous vous crée
toujours des dilemmes
oui j'aime bien c'est les paris mais
voilà mais ça c'est qu'a pris corps
c'est qu'après quand même et c'est bien
ah oui parce que j'y crois moi je suis
quand même quand ils sont un monde
s'écroule
alors là je dois lire mais vraiment mais
vraiment la boule de cristal l'astre du
jour n'ont même pas ma boule de cristal
mais c'est le prêtre en soit c'est linda
hardy comme l'astrologie sera pour une
autre fois l'armée c'est que les
capricornes je veux dire un truc je les
crois pas moi j'suis capricorne et je
vois comment tout ce que je lis dans les
journaux sud africains se vérifie voit
qu'on est un des dix points communs
ouais mais aujourd'hui on m'a dit tu vas
tomber sur une grange et sa santé sa
dette une grande histoire
moi aussi j'ai quatre cordes
c'était dans le parisien ce matin
sauf qu'elle est vierge et elle veut le
rester alors dans l'es4 car nous sommes
les biens en vieillissant c'est vrai oui
je crois et s'améliore en vieillissant
et ça va mieux l'un quand on a des
enfants et crozemarie l'été cancer
ascendant magasins et où tu vas aller
chercher à ces conneries tu as un pense
bête c'est hwa jai ho lundi à paco
rabanne les voyants c'est fait pour être
allumées bas ceci dit j'ai vu des
missions ouais il m'a fait peur je vois
pas pourquoi tu m'as pas invite à ce
jour là pourquoi face à la poche de
thorfinn soir que le seul nom c'est moi
je voulais si j'avais été là j'aurais
dit à paco rabanne voilà pas qu on va
faire un pari vous êtes persuadé ce que
vous dites moi je vous parie 5 % de
votre société
ouais d'accord et moi je vous parie 25 %
de ma société
ouais d'accord maintenant ça veut dire
que si ça fait le même chiffre
ibos 3000 tonnes le casting mais
pourquoi pourquoi pas fait ce pari avec
lui ouais mais il vit il y compte j'ai
senti qu'il était totalement convaincu
passant nous on a décidé avec catherine
barma de le réinviter dans la première
émission oz nombre ce sera à vous mais
il a une excuse pas de réponse dit qu'il
y avait justement il viendra s'asseoir à
mon avis c'est surtout c'est surtout le
12 août
enfin convaincu mais entre manger de
réciter un dessin de philippe geluck
dans l'événement du jeudi 7 semaines du
duc fait un des sujets sur le chat
gelade là le chat et et c'est le chat
qui dit paco rabanne quand on pense
qu'il a été farah au gardien d'empyr roi
de france faisait du ggyc maintenant
c'est devenu un vrai coup ion il n'a pas
de bol je suis dit ma beauté des choses
bon moi je viens on va s'arrêter là oui
parce que sinon après ça met une
mauvaise ambiance tout ça en cause au
nord parce que si je commence à lui
parler sa vie tout ça ça va on a
aujourd'hui tout va bien à la
chapellerie tu peux y aller alors là tu
peux y aller non je vais poser une
question orange aurait exactement les
mêmes réponses générales c'est pas ça
c'est que je disais que les capricornes
ça va mieux quand ils ont des enfants
oui et vous avez une très belle phrase
si je voulais terminer là dessus vous
avez une très belle phrase vous n'avez
pas connu votre mère puisque vous avez
été un enfant abandonné et vous dites je
vois ma mère dans les yeux de ma fille
oui mais faut faire attention à cette
phrase les peu dangereuse pourquoi parce
qu'il faut pas projeté je suis avant
tout un père mais c'est vrai que quand
ma fille aînée fictivement j'aurais
préféré avoir une fille qu'un garçon
parce que peut-être que le père m'ignore
ne me connaît pas à tandis que la mère
le sait que j'existe donc le fait
qu'elle soit qu'elles soient là devant
moi c'est le témoignage de ma mère c'est
assez beau de retrouver sa mère qu'on
n'a pas connues en portant un talent et
une chance de lui ressembler
j'aimerais bien aussi que je je veux
avoir quand même ma responsabilité de
père je sais qu'avant tout je suis un
père ça ces choses-là ses intérieurs
mais je suis un papa ça se passe bien
tant que papa papa me signale bond
extraordinaire
bon alors maintenant on va donc je
rappelle le titre du film donc oui il ya
smaïn film de lonval avec linda hardy on
dira encore un petit mot tout à l'heure
ça s'appelle donc recto verso
il ya beaucoup de petits mouvements
s'appelle recto verso ça sort le 16 juin